[Music]
nope
you're not mcdreaming that's mcdreamy
making fans make dreams come true with a
return to grey's anatomy
the hit show promised a shocking
jaw-dropping ending to the season 17
premiere on thursday
and they weren't kidding the final
seconds of the two-hour coronavirus
driven
episode revealed the shocking return of
patrick dempsey's beloved character
just a fast recap after meredith was
found
unconscious by mcwidow in the hospital
parking lot after grueling covid shifts
fans are transported into a dream
sequence where meredith sees a figure
waving at her from afar
when it dawns on her who it is she says
three little words that sum it all
up perfectly
but seriously oh my
god because it's derrick shepherd her
late husband and soul mate
who died tragically following
complications from a car crash in season
11.
and no this isn't the last you'll see of
mcdreamy
he'll be back for next week's episode
too showrunner krista vernoff said in a
statement to et
quote the beach motif which will
continue beyond the premiere
provided a way for us to live outside
the pandemic even for a little while
here and there
and derek's return provided joy for us
for meredith
and for the fans yes it did krista
yes it did and during an interview with
deadline
krista revealed it was actually ellen's
idea
and ellen well she told deadlines she
took a hike with her former co-star to
pitch the idea to him
quote i just said to him would you ever
consider coming and being a part of the
storytelling this season
there's just so much darkness and we
knew that coming together would be a
little ray of light
and patrick he told deadline the whole
experience was a very healing process
and really rewarding and a lot of fun
it was so fun because we know that we're
you know that people are gonna freak out
and
we all know 2020 has been a really
long ugly road ellen appeared on jimmy
kimmel live
after the show's premiere and gushed
over welcoming her on-screen hubby back
to the show
we were so happy just to be able to be
up you know to film these scenes and
know how much joy it was going to bring
people was really
we definitely had a ball patrick's last
episode up until this point
aired in april 2015 and in 2018
he told et he has nothing but love for
the cast and show
ellen pompeo paid you the biggest
compliment saying that you are a tough
act
to follow and that's why her character
has had a hard time finding love
how do you respond to that well that
yeah i mean it's um
i think the success of this [ __ ] that's
a wonderful compliment and thank you
and that was a very special bond that it
was just
there was a magic to our connection um
and
that's special and i think it started
with the original cast
and and the length that it has and there
are new people that come in and
uh you know it's amazing that it's
continuing to affect so many people it's
a really
a strong part of so many people's lives
and and young people are discovering it
um it's it's you're part of television
history and
it's really remarkable